let's start there john lynch general
manager of the team sitting with kyle
shanahan still adjusting to this new
reality of vaccinated executives and
coaches being fairly close to each other
with masks off talking here they are
talking about jimmy garoppolo and the
trade that went down four days ago
you know we both spoke to to uh to jimmy
kyle kyle did right away and then i did
later in the day
um you know i think um
i think the i'll let kyle go after this
but uh you know the the message was what
we were doing why we were doing it and
how he is very much still a pla a part
of our plans and uh
you know um i'm not not gonna um you
know i believe those conversations uh
should remain private but but uh
jimmy um he welcomes competition and so
i think i'll leave it at that and kyle
you go ahead um yeah very similar um you
know want to get it to jimmy definitely
before it came out so um called him
first thing had a good conversation with
him you know it's obviously no one wants
to hear that um and i know that he
wasn't totally excited about it like
you'd expect but jimmy handled it great
like he always does um we were very
straight up with each other and i told
him how he felt this doesn't mean
this isn't changes any of his
circumstances right now i mean he's
still coming in here trying to lead this
team i told him how excited i was that
free agency went a lot better than we
anticipated with being able to sign a
lot more of our own players than we had
thought going into it and that we got a
real good team coming back here and we
still plan on him leading us and getting
as far as we can with them
general observation and an invitation to
one of those two gentlemen i've got a
poker table down in my barn right john
lynch i will deal you in at any time
he's got more towels than there are
cards in the deck now kyle kyle has to
wait in the car i don't want kyle at the
table john lynch come on down let's play
some poker i mean he's fidgeting with
his watch he's doing this he's he was so
frazzled by trying to sell something
other than the actual god's honest truth
he's like shuffling papers afterwards
please just pass this off pass this off
to kyle and save me from this and this
all comes from my interpretation of
where this is going chris i don't think
jimmy garoppolo is on the week one
roster unless he ultimately takes a
dramatic pay cut that they may not
spring upon him until mid to late august
when it's too late for him to find
another destination if he says no thank
you and everyone else's depth chart is
full and if there is a need that's when
they could trade him maybe at a
dramatically reduced salary but i i
heard nothing yesterday and read nothing
as i studied the transcript to make me
think
that
he's our guy remember the anonymous leak
to shefty from friday jimmy's staying
jimmy's our guy yeah i didn't get that
impression yesterday yeah i mean mike
listen i i hear you and i know you're
you're being johnny the the card shark
there reading people but uh i get what
you mean there with john lynch he was a
little fidgety there's no doubt seemed a
little uncomfortable with that that
question well hey i mean the first thing
is
there's obviously somebody that they
want right at number three we know that
they've and it's a quarterback and it's
a quarter there's no doubt there's no
doubt i don't think anybody doubts that
at all right so we know there's somebody
there that has the eye of lynch and
shanahan and they look at him and go oh
we really think this guy can run the you
know organization and be special all
right who that is i don't know you know
i think it's mac jones but
you know they're they're
they're
like we talked about yesterday jimmy
garoppolo yeah they're in a good spot
they don't have to get rid of them they
don't but like we've talked about many
times it's risky getting rid of him uh
ever or not getting rid of him and
letting him start your year and then
having a good team and a good year and
all those things we've talked about
right so for me and for what you're
saying right now
yeah i i don't look at it like it's
going that way either i don't expect
jimmy g to be back i i just we've gotten
all these signs since the season's over
that you know they're trying to find a
replacement it sounds like now they got
their replacement and i just have a hard
time believing that they're going to go
into 2021 with jimmy g as their starting
quarterback and not go in with this guy
that they got at number three where they
got a big circle around it you know
shanahan's had success with young
quarterbacks before he did it with rg3
i'm sure he thinks whoa now i got a guy
that's you know
a drop back pass offense mac jones matt
ryan type guy i'm sure he thinks he can
have really big time results that way as
well so
i'm with you mike i have a hard time
believing that we'll see jimmy g as the
starting quarterback of the 49ers next
year
now time is on the 49ers side and i
think they need time for a couple of
reasons first of all they need to get
through the draft you never know what's
going to happen between now right and i
don't want to jinx max jones or anyone
else but but there could be anything
that can happen between now and april 29
that could cause the 49ers to go in a
different direction
then
then
once the guy is in your building
you have to be sure that number one he
is who you thought he was nod to dennis
green and second
he's got to be able to show that he's
ready to go week one maybe he's not
maybe he is a guy that needs to sit for
a while maybe you don't want to
undermine
2021 and get his career off to a bad
start by thrusting him into the fray i
remember when ben roethlisberger was put
in for tommy maddox in 2004 hall of fame
guard allen fanuc a very candid in his
criticism of going with a rookie
quarterback saying i don't want to show
up at my job with somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing do you do you
want to do that so that's part of the
balance they got to be ready
and they got to be sure that mac jones
can do it so that's another reason to
hold on to jimmy g he's a 25 million
dollar insurance policy until you no
longer need the insurance that's when
it's going to turn and i think that's
as they've planned this out and the
other thing that came through clear to
me yesterday yeah john lynch and kyle
shanahan have spent hours running
through
all of their options for upgrading at
quarterback this is all flowing from the
fact that they can't trust jimmy
garoppolo to be available to them that
is the root of this it's not how he
plays when he can play it's the fact
that he can't play enough you missed 23
games out of 48 in the regular season
that
is a major
problem and that's why they spent so
much time looking and there's a sense of
relief
now that they've picked a door i think
kyle
was going a little bit bonko's
by virtue of the fact that they still
had so many options we just got to pick
one sure we trade for matthew stafford
do we trade for deshaun watson do we
sign this guy do we go after this guy
what do we do what do we do what do we
do now they know
at least preliminarily right what
they're gonna do but there are still
more steps before we get to week one and
like i said time not only is on their
side they need time before they can make
their final move well you're right
you've said a lot of good things there i
mean you're right availability one thing
for sure you know jimmy g the play on
the field it's been good i don't think
we're gonna sit here and say it's been
great right it's had its moments of
where we go okay that's pretty good we
like it but of course like you've
brought up many times the playoffs the
times where you know the pressure's the
greatest
ah that was a questionable moment in the
super bowl run for the san francisco
49ers now you know you bring up like
like the the relaxation or shanahan at
peace because now they got a plan or
know what they're doing i mean agreed
they he finally controls his own fate as
far as and his destiny like we talked
about as far as who he can have at the
quarterback position now the other thing
i think that's interesting right
you bring up like the fact that hey they
they there's no reason to rush a trade
or do anything like that right the thing
they just have to balance i think and
and and i think you would agree here is
just
balancing the market and the want and
need for a guy like jimmy garoppolo
right now as compared to maybe yeah
taking your time going through some otas
and evaluating the situation with
whoever that quarterback is at three
compared to jimmy g
but you know the risk of that and and
doing that evaluation
is of course now the teams that needed
the quarterbacks find quarterbacks and
now you have nobody to trade the jimmy
garoppolo
which gets me back
to why
i think it's mac jones at number three
and here's all the reasoning because we
kind of just laid it out
you know this team this team's ready now
they're ready now and i just don't think
you do this
and trade up unless it's a quarterback
that's ready now too
and that's where i go back to mac jones
because i think out of all the guys in
the draft and you know i think zach
wilson's won as far as getting out of
the huddle checks reading plays the way
he was taught everything like that
nobody's more pro ready than mac jones
from that standpoint
and to me that also says that hey teams
ready we got a mature young quarterback
to come in who's run a pro style offense
already that just makes too much sense
and that's why i go back to your
original thought of i just don't expect
to see jimmy g as the quarterback of the
49ers next year
there are other factors that need to be
taken into account here as well you've
got players on that team that love the
guy right it's a cold hard business and
guys come and go all the time but you
need to have the players on board with
this transition so to the extent that if
there are otas this year and that's
still hanging in the balance but
whenever guys show up
you almost need to have an opportunity
for the players to see
wow this new guy yeah we like what he i
get it i get it now right i get it look
at how the ball comes in look at how he
executes the plays okay
and and it's just working through the
idea that
this guy can be our guy sorry jimmy we
love you but we want to win a super bowl
and we see now what kyle sees
in whoever it is mac jones or whoever
and i think that's part of the thought
process he knows he's got to sell this
to a locker room and he's confident that
he can
also a point that miles simmons made
yesterday on pftpm yeah
even if all the seats eventually are
full elsewhere and right now i don't
know where you would be able to trade
jimmy garoppolo he's going to have to
take less than 25 million no one is
touching that salary remember several
years ago
49ers broncos talking about a colin
kaepernick trade what did the broncos
want kaepernick to do reduces his salary
that would be part of any transaction
now but to the passage of time and it
was the same year 2016.
later that year what happens teddy
bridgewater catastrophic knee injury
what happens for the eagles sam bradford
supposedly the starter while rookie
carson wentz
gets himself ready right eagles have a
one and a four fall out of the sky a one
and a four yeah for a guy that they were
gonna bench at some point in 2016 if he
even was the week one starter right they
made that move a week and a half before
the start of the season so that's why
not just time from the standpoint of
getting the new guy ready time from the
standpoint of
all it takes is one practice one moment
one thing
and and and here's an opportunity to get
real value for this guy we gave up a
second-round pick for and gave millions
of dollars too i mean
you're those are all correct i mean
you're right that's why you do it
there's no doubt you get that team that
might be desperate in august and go wait
we think our team's good
we'll do anything to get somebody's good
quarterback oh there's jimmy g let's do
that you know i mean
certainly but i guess the risk and just
to play devil's advocate and then again
this is why i
would try to move jimmy g you know
sooner rather than later if i'm the
49ers is what if that doesn't happen
right all right so then you end up maybe
end up having just to cut him or do
something like that or who knows maybe
he's just on your roster but i also
think you run the risk of something you
brought up to the start of that
statement was you know the the massaging
of the locker room there a little bit
and again if you've got jimmy g in there
who's hey we've gone to the super bowl
with this guy and we like him and he's
cool and you know it's going to affect
the football team it will no matter what
people say as cool as george kittle is
right yeah he likes the new quarterback
whoever that may be mac jones everything
like that he's gonna like jimmy
garoppolo too you know and it can divide
the locker room and he's gonna feel more
loyal to jimmy garoppolo because that's
who he's known and been around more and
went to the super bowl with and i think
that's where
a head coach is gonna have a hard time
doing that at least i would if i had to
put myself in that shoes i'd be worrying
about that stuff and i just would want
to frame my team around my new guy and
let's go from there
well and i think part of it too is they
have to have a good read on how jimmy
garoppolo is going to react
necessary difficult conversation with
garoppolo look we don't want you
undermining what we're trying to do we
don't want you rallying support in the
locker room we see any sign of that
jimmy and this is not going to end well
you just need to show up and compete and
understand what we're trying to do as an
organization and
we we go into this with eyes wide open
we know that this has one year left at
the maximum right and if you want to
show the rest of the league
that you can be a productive starter
that you can stay healthy this is your
best opportunity you know this offense
you know this personnel and that's what
they're counting on they're counting on
jimmy g reacting in a way that if they
do need him he will perform well here's
shanahan talking about how he
anticipates garoppolo dealing with the
fact that he's now a short-timer in san
francisco
i'm sure jimmy was a little a little
pissed off from it just like i would be
too um but me knowing jimmy he'll be
fired up and come in and he'll work his
butt off and
knowing jimmy it
usually the more mad jimmy gets usually
the better he gets um so it's you know
jimmy just gets madder and he stays
healthy i mean this is going to be a
good thing for jimmy too which could be
a great problem for the 49ers um so i'm
i hope jimmy's all right with it and i
expect him to be and i'm excited to have
him come in here and see what he's been
doing while he's away and
hopefully we'll have a team here that we
can work and practice with which as john
just said i think will eventually happen
i hate that phrase great problem or good
problem the only good problem is no
problem you want no problem yeah and
it's better to have no problem than a
great problem so i think the ideal
scenario for the 49ers is
they find a way out they find an offer
right where they can say
we got something for a guy that we were
gonna go to august 28 and say
we want you to take a 12 million dollar
pay cut and if you don't we're gonna cut
you
all right we got something for him
instead this worked this was a win for
us and i think that is what they're
trying to implement chris i i mean yes i
i would imagine so and i would imagine
too
you know hey
you check all your boxes here if you're
the 49ers organization you know they're
going to see the mac jones work out
today
going to do that do all their homework
as far as you know meeting the guy on
zoom everything like that
you know again wait to the probably the
last possible second just in case
something crazy happens doesn't happen
whatever that may be
but i i expect that sometime towards
draft somewhere in that week leading up
to it we start to hear
some some shatter on jimmy g and being
traded i i just i i just i i don't know
i just don't see it going down any other
way i'd be shocked i really would be and
you know you again we talked about it a
little yesterday but uh carolina's
sitting that sitting there and i go
jimmy g fits that offense he would fit
that west coast joe burrow you know let
me get in the pocket and make a lot of
five and ten yard throws and pick you
apart that way he would he would fit
that and then of course the other team i
come to is the denver broncos because i
just have a hard time thinking they're
gonna roll out the red carpet for drew
lock in such a big year so you look at
those two teams and you go man you can
get them bidding against each other a
little bit for a guy that's a pretty
damn good quarterback not a top 10
quarterback but i think somewhere mike
to be fair what do you think
anywhere from 15 to 20 maybe jimmy g as
far as the nfl is concerned uh i think
then you may you might have something as
far as where you get those two teams
going against each other
the inability to be healthy on a
consistent basis at the position other
than punter and kicker that is more
protected than any other on the field
yeah it's scary it troubles me it does
more than anything else yeah and also
also
the the hole into which kyle stuck his
head during the playoffs in 2019 bothers
me that resonates that moment where he
freaked out
we're just going to run the ball and run
the ball and run the ball until we have
two weeks to come up with a game plan
that we can maybe implement to help kyle
against the chiefs in the super bowl
that bob greasy run
i i can't forget that and it's amazing
to me how many 49ers fans just kind of
gloss over that when evaluating jimmy
garoppolo and ultimately i assume 49ers
fans just want to win the super bowl but
a lot of people don't want new they're
afraid of new yeah they're afraid that
new is gonna upset what we've got and oh
if jimmy can just stay healthy but what
other quarterback in the nfl right now
other than maybe cam newton do we apply
to the if he can just stay healthy right
you don't you just don't you don't want
that and it's obvious
it's obvious folks the fact that the
49ers made this move it was motivated by
one thing
they're sick and tired of having to
worry about whether or not their
quarterback is going to be healthy
that's right period that's if you can't
stay healthy at that position
you can't be a franchise quarterback
yeah i mean you know
all the things you said the playoff run
you talked about the super bowl forget
about the last throw there was a lot of
plays in the second half of the football
game that i know i broke down here on
nbc sports and did things where i just
went no this is the wrong read the wrong
play all those things freaked out
freaked out by chris jones batting the
ball down and nervous wide open
didn't even look didn't even look
because the ball had been batted down
there's the button
there's all those issues exactly right
so you know you have that then the you
know not being able to be available
issue and that is a real issue
especially when your team is really damn
good you know and that's where you know
again you know i just laugh
you know but but one thing is like
people people making fun of like right
mac jones right oh he's not a good
enough athlete do those things i want to
go well no you know everybody thinks you
can win a super bowl with jimmy
garoppolo and i promise you mac jones is
a better athlete than jimmy garoppolo i
can promise you that his feet are better
in the pocket he's better on the run
he's faster straight away he could do
things like that he's a level up that
way too and i think too you know again
that that guy looks as looked at like a
dinosaur a little bit right where
garoppolo
is the guy
mac jones is the before and garoppolo is
the after i mean that's what the people
people are gonna people are gonna react
by saying are you where are you but
you're so you're gonna have to sell this
yeah because garoppolo is the guy who
who looks like he's in shock i know cut
he's puffed right he's the better
athlete in the eyes of most people why
are you saying jones is better because
jones has incredible hop around you know
crossover move your feet oh no i was
gonna throw here wait i gotta readjust
and throw it over there in a hurry he's
incredible that way garoppolo is slow
footed i mean that's one of the reasons
garoppolo has been injured is he really
can't get out of harm's way at times
it's kind of how he hurt his shoulder
when he was with new england and even
this year with the jets his legs were
kind of planted in the ground
you know and of course there's the dumb
mistake he made in kansas city that you
brought up before too you know so
there's got to be a question of wait can
he get himself out of the way uh is he
smart enough to get himself out of the
way and not be stupid that way you know
those are all there but mac jones yeah
despite what he looks like man i mean
the the way he moves in the pocket it
it's really damn good i mean it's
special for a college quarterback
and
and it's legit quickness in his feet
that way and yeah he doesn't look as
adonis as jimmy garoppolo but i'll take
him in a race or a 5 10 5 or anything
like that against jimmy garoppolo any
any day of the week as far as that's
concerned
i suspect that the moment that jimmy
garoppolo was running for the sideline
at arrowhead stadium and saw a defensive
back and decided to drop his shoulder
and deliver a blow and tore his acl in
the progress in the process kyle
shanahan said something along the lines
of are you
bleeping kidding me and that may have
been the moment where the worm turned
against jimmy garoppolo in san francisco
just took a couple of years for it to
get to this point now moving forward
yeah alabama pro day two today they had
one last week this was confusing
yesterday mac jones threw last week well
they can't do private workouts this year
so you're going to see multiple pro day
workouts so today
jones throwing again
kyle in attendance here he is talking
about attending the alabama pro day and
the guy he's undoubtedly there to watch
mac jones
i normally don't like to go to him a
bunch unless i feel i need i have to
unless i have to for some reason but
i also have been kind of grown up in the
idea that you don't like to go
everywhere and show people things and
when you're sitting at 12 and stuff i
don't want to go to a bunch of
quarterback pro days and things like
that um now that you move up to three
you don't have to hide as much it's not
as big of a deal to me as it might have
been when we were sitting at 12.
the way we looked at it is i mean to
move up to three
we had to feel good that there's three
guys we'd be comfortable with leading
our team for a long time and we couldn't
make that decision before there was
three guys so we had to feel that way
with three um now i think there's a
chance to get there with four and five
there's a chance
there's five guys that are kind of at
this party a little bit and people are
talking about them going everywhere
they're all over in the first round our
feeling is these guys are going to go a
lot higher than people realize and when
you have two guys sitting out one and
two possibly could um even possibly
three and four then you hear a lot of
teams um all the way through the draft
who are in a situation where they really
want a quarterback and they don't have
someone close to what we have with jimmy
um
that means those five guys are gonna
disappear pretty fast so we had to feel
confident in three to make this move um
and that's what we did and i do it i'm
excited about now we know there's five
players who do you want to put your
um who do you want to put your future in
well i'm glad we got a month to really
work on that
you know what when when i hear that last
part
and there's no reason for him to be coy
at this point he controls the board
after trevor lawrence and then
presumably zach wilson
but he says there's five guys i assume
he's talking about mac jones justin
fields and trey lance yeah you got a
month to figure out which guy you really
want right even if he has a lien right
now there's no reason
to put a flag in the ground
and also you know no one wants to
undermine the ultimate reality show we
talked about that yesterday with urban
meyer being coy about taking
uh trevor lawrence at number one so yeah
there's no there's no reason to say mac
jones is the guy there's no reason to
get anyone's expectations moving in a
certain direction because this is part
of what they paid for they just like the
rams in 2016 they they traded up for the
ability to have the number one overall
pick and jeff fisher was going to enjoy
every second of having the unexercised
number one overall pick at a certain
level the 49ers can enjoy the next month
where everyone's going to be talking
about what are they going to do because
along the way they're talking about the
49ers and there's this this effort to
constantly be consuming the news cycle
49ers are going to be at the top of it
chris until we know who they pick yeah
that's right i mean the speculation is
going to continue but you know i think
that there was enough context clues just
right there in that little segment to
tell you who it's gonna be i mean i only
go when it's important to the pro day oh
that's right wait you're going to the
pro day that there's the quarterback
everybody's linking to you sounds like
it might be kind of important you know
and just
again just with like you know not having
to hide and do all of those things and
talking about three quarterbacks that
you know you're comfortable with to me
that just screams
you know the top three guys and wilson
lawrence and mac jones is
and and to what he's saying like listen
trey lance and fields have some elite
ability about them they can be something
but i'll go back to what i originally
tweeted on friday and what you heard me
say i just don't think those are the
guys you trade up in the draft for right
now you don't trade up for guys who need
work or project or projections to where
oh you know i like this trey lance but
he hasn't played a lot and hasn't thrown
a lot i think he could be something to
me that's not what you do you trade up
for guys where you go like
no
i think this guy's i'm going to go from
27 to 10 because i think this guy's the
man oh that's right it's patrick mahomes
you know buffalo making the trade to get
up to get josh allen i mean to me that's
the guy you do it for you don't do it
for the project the project is more to
me
along the lines of you would see like
with jordan love last year where oh wait
we'll take you in the 20s or a team
trades up you know to get out of the top
of the second round to get in back up
into the first round because wait we see
high end talon here but not like a top
10 or top 15 pick uh and there's some
work and that's where again i just think
it screams mac jones and would be
shocked that the 49ers don't go that way
even though kyle shanahan and john lynch
are attending the alabama pro day today
when the ohio state pro day is happening
the same day and it's caused many to say
aha aha
it's mac jones not justin fields they're
setting up a pro day two
for ohio state right so that shanahan
can personally witness justin fields and
they're going to do one north dakota
state for trey lance so they have to do
their homework you never know what will
happen over the course of the next month
you have to feel good about it this is
now i think though confirmation not
elimination as it relates to the guy
he's leaning out with number three and i
have no reason to dispute your
assessment of mac jones being the guy
this whole idea of secrecy that reminded
me yesterday yeah of 2006 chris and you
may or may not remember this
the broncos were at 15. mike shanahan
was the head coach
the rams go on the clock at 11. boom
there's a trade
the broncos move up to 11. take jay
cutler vanderbilt quarterback they had
done nothing right with cutler they
hadn't gone to see him no workout no
visit no nothing no interview cutler was
floored and and that's the house
that kyle grew up in he soaked up so
much knowledge from the way his dad did
things and as it relates to the draft
you can never
show
your hand no which which dovetails with
all of our points about garoppolo and
which is why while i'm taking john
lynch's chips down in the barn playing
poker kyle can sit up in the car talking
to you because i ain't playing poker
with him cause he learned from his dad
how to do it chris yeah well hey it's
business shanahan's been around it for a
long long time and like you've said
there's no reason at this point to let
anybody know you know you've still got a
lot of time here
to do your you know cross all your t's
dot all your eyes see these guys in
person you know yes
i would think that there was a serious
lean towards one guy as in fact like we
made this trade because of this guy
certainly but could his mind change
over the next month if he went to go
evaluate all three of these guys and the
guy he thought he was gonna take
you know he looked at and went oh i
don't love what i'm seeing here and this
other guy's better than than what i
think yeah minds could be changed
especially if like you looked at it from
the angle of hey okay he moved up for
mac jones at number three
but
he also really likes trey lance right
and he's not wouldn't be mad to have him
either you know there could be that
possibility of thinking like you know
really any of these guys i'm okay with
here as i go into this process but now
i'm assured of getting my top three as
kind of what he's saying there and how
he sees it and uh that's why you don't
you know tip your hand to this point but
i i would think there's a real lean and
a real guy that they have targeted
already and that's why you make this
trade
one thing that kyle shanahan won't have
to worry about if he drafts mac jones is
a john elway eli manning type of a power
play jones already sounds like he's all
in with the prospect of being the 49ers
quarterback here he is talking about
that san francisco offense under kyle
i've watched their tape and stuff i've
got a chance to watch a lot of um you
know everybody but 49ers specifically
obviously they run a lot of wide zone
they also have a great full back so they
can run power and they do a bunch of
good play pass off of that so outside
zone sprint out stuff
you know obviously their drop back
passing game is really similar to what
we did with sarc
and you know some of their motions that
they use i noticed they got the
boomerang motions and the cap motions
across the ball fast so that's all stuff
that i'm really familiar with
and obviously it's a super quarterback
friendly offense and they have great
playmakers there
so i'm really looking forward to just
learning more about that
oh looking forward to learning more
about that well you won't need to if
you're on a different team max so mac do
you know something either
it sounds like mac knows something like
the rest of us don't right uh so and and
look mac is represented by jimmy sexton
and sexton's been doing it forever he
knows which way the wind is blowing and
i have a feeling that mac knows which
way the wind is blowing and it's blowing
in his direction unless he blows it
today i mean look
this is part of it even though the pro
days are scripted and perfunctory he's
got to perform with kyle shanahan and
john lynch standing there watching him
that's not that there's any reason to
think he's going to fail the guy won the
national championship but this is just
part of the check the box check the box
check the box and that's going to happen
today yeah
different kind of pressure definitely
and he's going to have his receivers
today i i would think we're going to see
a little bit of a different mac jones
maybe a little bit more of a showman you
know during this workout compared to
what we saw last week right
i i really do that was one thing i was a
little disappointed with mac jones last
week i just wish he would have gone out
and been a little bit more of a show off
you know you see on film some different
type of throws and you know him being
able to let it go and not that he's got
the strongest arm in the draft but his
arm is stronger than people want to give
it credit for we saw it last week with
he threw a ball 67 something yards in
the air too you know so
that this is a different kind of
pressure he's gonna deal with today
but
uh i hope he lets it fly a little bit
more than he did last week and doesn't
kind of protect the ball to be so
perfect and accurate and do all of those
things but again mac jones too just to
back to the offense part you know
there he is i've watched the offense he
gives you a good idea i mean just just
the way he talks there you could tell
this guy's he's a football guy he really
is and he's already comfortable with
some of the things he's seen within that
offense because hey i've done that
listen if
if you're an offensive coach
i mean a lot of the smart ones are
watching kyle shanahan and what he does
because he's so cutting edge that way
and there's of course some of that in
that alabama offense that if he does
take over for the 49ers it'll be
seamless for him and it won't be any
issue at all
amazing to think that before last year
alabama had a grand total from
the super bowl era onward of two
quarterbacks taken
in round one joe namath richard todd and
i think even it goes beyond the super
bowl air i think it's ever it was joe
namath and richard todd right
tuatagobilo and mack jones poised top
five picks
back to back it shows you where we had
just
had this notion this impression this
perception that alabama is all defense
all defense all defense meanwhile the
offense kind of secretly and quietly has
gotten pretty damn good and cutting edge
and it it makes the receivers
and now the quarterbacks ready to be
plugged into an nfl offense and thrive
and look at look at the prospects look
at so many of them that are from the
offensive side of insane and it really
has become an nfl factory since
nick saban said i'm not going to be the
alabama coach
plenty of guys have put themselves in
position to make plenty of money by
virtue of the fact that he did chris
yeah and you know mike your your fact
your fact about the the offense that
that's real i mean that's where i give
nick saban a lot of credit he changed he
realized that whoa college the way the
game's being played the rules everything
like this it's hard to be a shutdown
we're going to stop you cold defense and
hold you to 20 points a game anymore so
he said you know what i'm going to get
start getting more speed and i'm going
to start being explosive on offense and
that's what they've become the last few
years where it's well it's alabama you
just go
they're gonna outscore you they're gonna
score 40. can you score 40 with them i
mean two receivers gonna go in the top
20 this year you know two two in the top
20 last year it is it's it's it's
amazing what they've done there and uh
it's a extremely they're the kings of
college football it's not even close
it's why he's one of the greatest
college football coaches of all times i
would say he is the greatest college
football coach of all time the question
whether he's the greatest football coach
of all time that's a different debate
altogether because of his record at the
miami dolphins
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports